hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to
when people think slapstick they usually
think the Three Stooges Charlie Chaplin
Buster Keaton and of course cartoons but
not just cartoons there's some that
stand out more than usual the Looney
Tunes Tom and Jerry but people rarely
put Disney cartoons in there as majority
of them just seemed more like kid stuff
I mean okay a little kick and watch any
of this and enjoy it but it usually
takes a certain amount of cleverness and
effort to make it so that you enjoy it
as an adult and Disney cartoons didn't
always well there were certainly
artistically pleasing cartoons there
were more for adults The Adventures of
say Mickey Mouse were usually seen as
more aimed towards kids than grown-ups
Donald Duck is the only one who adults
can relate to and thus he's seen as the
only one who can get a laugh sometimes
but everyone always overlooks one
comedic badass before that after that
yes I am talking about the Golden Age of
goofy now when you think goofy you think
of him tripping over stuff letting out a
little laugh not very smart comedy well
that's because that's the more
kid-friendly and marketable goofy that
you see everywhere what they don't show
you is the goofy that violent angry a
smoker a psychopath and abusive parent
and one of the friggin funniest
characters to ever come out of Disney
yet people just kind of glance over this
comedy because they still associate him
with sheep laughs but there are a ton of
hilarious cartoons they're not only
funny but would be considered actually
kind of shocking today here's a joke for
example that no kid would get but a lot
of adults would actually can't drop
their jaws at goofy stays home with his
son not max as his wife takes a day for
herself for taking in hugely offensive
woman driver jokes she made Wow
when a milkman rings the doorbell here's
how he greet what he thinks is Goofy's
wife
oh yeah goofy just made an adulterer a
joke in a Disney cartoon the dog went
there what makes it even funnier is that
it's a running gag everyone at the door
greets him the exact same way to the
point where he's actually kind of
expecting it dude his wife kids around
from Lucas how's this for a good dad
when the baby is crying at night he's
told to get up and get the bottle and
that's exactly what he does he goes to
the kitchen and helps himself to some
scotch drowning out the crying of his
child so he can sleep better
yikes on top of threatening his kid with
violence and even tying him up when he's
goofing off in the car that's not the
same character they've been marketing
all these years the reason he was
portrayed like this is where Mickey was
kind of a big eyed innocent kid and
Donald a spoil angry kid goofy was
supposed to be the everyman as in adult
so the humor for a while represented the
exaggerations of what a suburban adult
male would experience for example road
rage there's an episode where he starts
off totally normal but when he gets
behind a car he becomes a complete
psychopath practically running over
anyone who gets in his way
watch where you're going stupid
there's even an episode I'm shocked they
still play we're goofy tries to give up
smoking so the majority of it is just
him looking for a cigarette smoke smoke
problems Wow
no kid is gonna understand the kind of
addiction effective anything I think it
kind of glorifies it a bit
it's a Phyllis Morrison that's so
uncomfortable but adults will completely
get it and laugh their asses off and
because he was the everyman they put him
in a variety of jobs which just let them
more open for more adult jokes just take
a guess what these kids are whispering
about even when he's a private eye they
really go far with some disturbing
imagery you wouldn't see today on most
kids shows but they're still incredibly
funny partly because they are so
shocking
but if goofy has the everyman is
surprisingly kind of intense you can
always turn to him playing sports
certainly that must be innocent right
and this is where you see him at his
most violent most of us know the ones
where he's a lo and it again messes up
with a playful chuckle the while those
are well done they're not nearly as in
your face or as violent as the one where
there's millions of it you see it got to
a point with a slapstick with goofy was
so popular it made sense just to make a
lot more but rather than just give him
some nephews or a family they populated
the whole world with it and when it was
a sports episode it was some of the
funniest violence you'll ever see it
wouldn't be funny if they were all just
happy idiots because then the conflict
between the characters would be weakened
so they drew up much more angry and
mean-spirited designs in fact in these
episodes they never refer to any of
these characters as goofy they have
regular names like George or Ralph but
not one of them was ever called goofy
this meant they could make them as blood
hungry as they wanted with no
repercussions
and that's exactly what they did they
mix that angry conflict with brilliant
slapstick hilarious expressions and some
of the funniest yells ever assembled
and don't forget the classic look at the
speed of this but at the same time you
feel the impact of every punch every
amount of pain that happens you get a
laugh at because it looks like it really
hurts but the raging testosterone keeps
them vengeful and moving so the momentum
never slows down
goofy suddenly became less about a silly
character in a normal world and more
about a crazy world that eerily
reflected ours one of my favorites is
one of the fans of a hockey game are so
caught up in the violence and fighting
for their team that they rush the ice in
a riot beating the crap out of each
other by the end they get so wrapped up
in it that they don't realize the
players have stopped playing and are now
the audience observing them as the
spectacle so yeah goofy cartoons even
kind of have good commentary if you're
wondering why many of these turned out
so funny is because most of them were
directed by a man named Jack Hanna his
detail in slapstick is amazing and if
you watch it in slow-mo you see just how
well planned out the timing the
expressions and the impact of every hit
is he also directed a lot of Donald Duck
cartoons again usually the ones that had
the most slapstick and even kind of a
mean-spirited nature to them well a lot
of everyday people probably don't know
him he's created comedy just as on par
as hanna-barbera Tex Avery and Chuck
Jones and in my opinion is a comedic
animation giant the cartoons he's
created are beyond hilarious and they
deserve to be seen by anyone who loves
good comedy there's a lot of collections
out there but probably the best one is
the complete goofy bar the Walt Disney
treasures collection just two DVDs of
absolute awesomeness so the next time
you think of goofy is just a chuckling
moron who knows oh he'll oh cool
remember this Oh
yeah Goofy's extreme if you haven't seen
these cartoons or you just trade out
forgot about them definitely go and
observe that there's a lot more for
adults here than you would think
go see the great animation the great
voice work and the hilarious comedy that
proved this character is much more than
just a silly laugh ah shut up I'm gonna
start a critic I remember so you don't
have to
everybody dog-walker here doing the
charity shout out and this week we are
doing I love the title to this one
cradles to crayons they provide children
from birth through age 12 living on
homeless or low-income situations with
the essential items they need to thrive
at home at school at play anywhere a
child is expected to be they supply
these items free of charge by engaging
and connecting communities that have
with communities that need they collect
new and nearly new children's items
through grassroot community drives and
corporate donations donations are then
processed and packaged by volunteers and
are distributed to disadvantaged
children across the states specifically
Massachusetts Pennsylvania and Illinois
through a collaborative network of
social service agencies and school
partners when you think of your
childhood and all the wonderful things
that you had growing up think of the
children who don't have those things
growing up and need those things growing
up go to their website or check out
their YouTube channel to see all that
they do they're good people with a good
cause and you yourself can be doing good
by clicking on the link and showing your
support